yann depardieu bonsoir alors faites-vous
confiance à l'hôpital nous allons
connaître l'opinion des français sur ce
sujet j'imagine la vôtre oui
malheureusement pas trop confiance c'est
pas ça c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire on je pense vous
reprenez goût à la vie alors la douleur
dit vous est parti à 80 %
il me reste des douleurs fantômes mais
c'est quasiment le paradis par rapport à
ce que j'ai vécu
oui presque paraguay et le paradis avec
une jambe en moins à quoi un peu
contrariant à 32 ans ce que vous avez
vécu c'est à dire l'amputation bien
entendu de la moitié de votre jambe
suite à un grave accident de moto en
1995 une valise mal attachées sur le
toit du véhicule qui vous précède et
guillaume fractures ouvertes destruction
du genou et 17 opérations après jusqu'à
une infection due à un staphylocoque
résistant à tout traitement antibiotique
et vous découvrez qu'il s'agit d'une
infection nosocomiale ce qu'on appelle
une maladie d'hôpital en général vous
découvrez également que plus aucun
médicament ne parvient à atténuer votre
souffrance malgré les dose massive
d'antibiotiques de morphine
le seul résultat finalement c'est de
vous bougiez l'estomac vous avez vomi du
sang
oui j'ai même attrapé un ulcère enfin
bref tout où le tous les à-côtés
souhaitable qu on a évidemment quand on
prend des idées soulevées dose massive
d'antibiotiques
jusqu'à ce que vous trouviez à un
chirurgien qui acceptent de deux vous
amputez les autres étaient pas vraiment
d'accord pourquoi ça pose un gros
problème quand même pas ce que ça veut
dire que si presque 1 plutôt un constat
d'échec
en l'occurrence c'est un constat d'échec
mais en même temps bon j'avais le choix
entre avoir une jambe raide toute ma vie
donc marcher dix ans et puis après avoir
le dos bousier puis après avoir une
autre en cinq mois c'est me faire opérer
du col du fémur à 40 ans alors
normalement c'est l'intervention qui
vient sauver les personnes âgées note
donc j'ai préféré couper court alors
aujourd'hui vous militez pour que
d'autres ne subissent pas le même
calvaire car pour vous l'hôpital et
dangereux en fait je suis venu à cette
première démission parce que c'est pour
son titre déjà opinion publique et puis
le fait aussi que des gens informés sont
réunis ici un jeu voit donc on va
regarder les problèmes de l'hôpital
magnéto serge dans l'hôpital idéal les
usagers auraient accès à des
informations claires sur l'établissement
qualité des soins enquête des services
sanitaires système de notation le
personnel soignant en nombre suffisant
pourrait consacrer le temps nécessaire à
chaque patient et respecter les
protocoles d'hygiène l'hôpital seraient
équipés des moyens technologiques les
plus modernes et les plus sûres temps
pour les équipes médicales que pour les
patients
mais dans la vraie vie l'hôpital est en
pleine crise depuis la catastrophe
sanitaire dus à la canicule de cet été
la moindre épidémie fait resurgir
l'extrême fragilité du système on voit
face à ces situations exceptionnelles
des plans blancs se mettre en place
je dirais qu'au niveau des urgences et
dans beaucoup d'établissements on est
ensemble en 24 heures sur 24 365 jours
par an que le manque de lits qu'un
problème auquel on est confronté en
permanence lui l'arrivée d'un patient
amenées par le samu qui a peut-être une
place dans le service de réanimation à
30 kilomètres d'ici en faire le bilan
aux apports sait on si on y envoie
toujours est il qu'il n'ya par exemple
cherchera pas de lits de réanimation
dans le pouvoir qu'il soit disponible
donc d'argent et de matériel
démotivation du personnel pénurie
d'infirmières et d'un terne
l'hôpital ne peut plus assurer son vrai
rôle de service public
offrir des soins de qualité à tous ses
biens services qui doivent fonctionner
avec
cinq ou six médecins et quand vous
retirez ceux qui sont en repos
compensateur ceux qui sont en vacances
et ceux qui ont posé des rtt souvent se
retrouve à deux ou trois donc quasiment
50% en moins donc c'est les gens vont
attendre trois quatre cinq six heures
avant d'être examiné parce que tu fasses
on ne pourra pas aller plus vite faute
d'effectifs pas sur une petite journée à
50 patients
on est une infirmière et une aide
soignante et vous voyez on n'avait pas
cette période de congés il ya plus qu
une infirmière et une aide soignante
pour 80 passages donc c'est nos deux
principaux problèmes
un des problèmes de personnel et deux
des problèmes de l'île qu'il n'ya plus
grands les hôpitaux pour accueillir les
patients j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
espèce de de ras-le-bol de lassitude un
petit peu des personnels en général
depuis quelques années si les conditions
de travail sont éprouvantes pour le
personnel
elles peuvent s'avérer dangereuses pour
les usagers le grand public découvre que
l'on peut tomber malade à l'hôpital
ces infections porte un anneau les
maladies nosocomiales
officiellement huit cent mille personnes
contractent chaque année une infection
au milieu hospitalier qui provoque la
mort de plus de 4000 patients par an 97
le scandale éclate à la clinique du
sport ou des patients tous infectés au
cours d'une opération porte plainte
les instruments été stérilisés puis
rincer à l'eau froide
erreur fatale dans l'eau se trouve une
bactérie tueuse le xenopie nous avons
demandé à l'ordre des médecins en effet
de se pencher sur cette affaire mais
encore une fois je pense surtout aux
malades je voudrais surtout que ceux qui
ont été opérés dans cette clinique
ne passez pas à côté des vérifications
nécessaires n'en disons pas plus pour le
moment ne diabolisons par les choses
bernard kouchner alors ministre de la
santé fait voter une loi en 2002
imposant un contrôle sanitaire des
hôpitaux mais le sujet reste tabou
il faut attendre que guillaume depardieu
expose son drame à la une des médias
pour qu'enfin on brise le silence avant
de la fendre la vérité c'est quand même
deux ans de mensonges
enfin j'exagère un an et demi un an et
demi je suis assez à l'hôpital j'ai tout
perdu
je suis tout perdu j'étais perdu 18
kilos espoirs ça détruit tout 16 et
ravagent tout est ce assez
c'est inadmissible qu'on entend encore
même alors qu'on sait ce qui se passe
depuis son coup de gueule médiatiques
il reçoit tous les jours des lettres des
témoignages de détresse d'autres malades
infectés soulagé de trouver enfin
quelqu'un qui ose dénoncer publiquement
le silence des médecins tiens bon alors
elle est courte on va la faire courte je
trouve ça très bien que ce qu'a fait
monsieur guillaume depardieu je suis
désolé de ce qui lui est arrivé il ya
quatre ans mon grand père a décidé de la
suite d'une infection nosocomiale il
avait la maladie de parkinson depuis
plus de 30 ans alors là on se dit tout
de suite oui mais les vieux c'est normal
c'est la faute à pas de chance
en 1997 il entre à l'hôpital pour une
occlusion intestinale plusieurs jours
après son entrée il a eu une forte
fièvre
ça c'est les premiers symptômes à la
forte fièvre les médecins m'ont soigné
mais non pas chercher la cause de
septième nous avons appris plus tard
qu'il avait attrapé un staphylocoque
doré et qu'il était en train de lui
ronger la valves du coeur ça ça pardonne
pas traqué aux six mois il n'est jamais
rentré chez lui céder sans que nous
soyons avec lui en une semaine
j'espère que vous pourrez faire quelque
chose c'est pourquoi moi
comme guillaume narc été victime d'un
accident de moto
emmenée aux urgences il est soigné pour
une fracture ouverte dix jours plus tard
les ennuis commencent
suite à une deuxième intervention
au bloc opératoire il ya eu un pic de
fièvre
ils ont fait des prélèvements à ce
moment là ils ont vu qu'il y avait une
infection enfin il y avait un germe
infectieux
il n'a jamais été dit par les médecins
du premier établissement qu'il y avait
un fiction nosocomiales de toute manière
on laisse pas les gens comme ça pendant
six mois se dégrade de se dégrader
psychologiquement et physiquement
surtout jusqu'à n'être plus qu'un cri
enfin mon credo douleur et rien d'autre
après cinq ans d'hospitalisation et 36
opérations sa jambe n'est plus infecté
il ne pourra jamais plus vivre comme
avant
tout s'annonçait radieux un enfant à
venir une progression professionnelle
parce qu'elle était prévu que j'ai une
promotion dans l'établissement où je
travaillais ça peut être été trop de
bonheur ma couche c'est pas marqué est
obligé de se lancer dans un marathon
judiciaire pour que l'hôpital avoue sa
responsabilité pour son avocat
spécialiste de ce type d'affaires le
premier établissement qui l'a opéré a
commis des fautes vous voir arriver un
cas particulièrement difficile tant en
orthopédique en infectiologie et aux
lieux simplement de dire on sait pas
faire on le garde dans l'établissement
hospitalier et ont fait absolument tout
travers le tribunal va désigner un
expert celui ci demande l'avis d'un
sapiteur un spécialiste en affection à
l'arrivée de rapport totalement
contradictoire
pour le spécialiste marque est victime
d'une infection nosocomiale
mais l'expert n'est pas d'accord on a eu
le sentiment qu'en fait il voulait pas
tenir compte de cet avis du cpie trafic
ce blog
parce que peut-être qu'ils étaient trop
sévères vis-à-vis de l'établissement
hospitalier
les conclusions de l'expert sont sans
appel d'après lui mark n'a pas contracté
de maladies nosocomiales
nous l'avons rencontré pour tenter de
comprendre sa décision
on a un cas précis en crète pour lequel
vous êtes intervenu et pour lequel nous
avons rapport le cas de marc reinecke et
alors donc vous avez écarté d'un revers
de la main le compte-rendu l' expertise
du sanitaire est pourquoi pourquoi mais
ce qui masque il nous a paru règles très
révélateur c'est la vie visiblement du
c'est peter reconnaît une maladie
nosocomiale
c'est peu c'est pas c'est pas totalement
impossible mais le problème est pas là
le problème est pas le problème d'une
infection il dit la plus d'infections
s'était il avait été opéré en [ __ ] est
dur et de remblai comme on faisait ya 50
ans et serait c'était pratiquement
justifié hors du coup maintenant il a le
droit à rien
la peur des poursuites judiciaires a
provoqué des réactions malsaine dans
l'univers médical
guillaume a souhaité que nous
rencontrions des infirmières qui vont
soigner elle s'exprime anonymement
difficile de briser l'omerta
hospitalière quand il s'agit de maladies
nosocomiales
pourquoi on sait c'est peut-être que
chacun jeudi avant on va le dire on va
pas le dire la toute façon le malade
risque de se retourner contre nous et
chacun essaie d'ouvrir le parapluie en
disant pourvu que ça me retombe pas
dessus parce que les gens portent
plainte à engendrer des comportements
qui sont très malsain parce qu'à mon
avis la crainte n'est éclaboussures fait
qu'on ne dit rien parfois même des
médecins laisse partir des patients
infectés plutôt que de les prévenir
d'une éventuelle aggravation 5 les
médecins ont tendance à ne pas dire que
quand ils le disent aux patients vous
êtes guéri
c'est vrai que là on y réfléchissant il
faudrait bien mieux lui dire ce qu'ils
étaient informés reviennent tout de
suite ceux qui n'ont pas été informés
reviennent beaucoup plus tard est
souvent là ils en prennent pour un
moment
paradoxe du système c'est dans un
hôpital privé à la croix saint simon
qu'un services spécialisés accueillent
les victimes d'infections venus de tous
les hôpitaux de france après un accident
de moto
david a été infectée au cours d'une
opération mais son cas était trop
critique la clinique ne pouvait plus
rien faire pour lui
donc on a dit on on lui a demandé si
vous pouvez nous envoyer quelque part il
a dit moi je peux pas vous dire où
mais pardon vous pouvez chercher rien et
quand j'arrive à l'hôpital public on m'a
foutu à la porte quand on m'a vu avec ce
que j'avais on m'a dit monsieur vous
sortez pour parce que j'avais une
infection nosocomiale et vous l'époque
je le ramène leur infection chez eux à 2
heures du matin j'étais doré pas malice
coiffage j'attends il y a quelques
semaines 191 médecins des hôpitaux
publics ont adressé une lettre ouverte
au ministre de la santé pour l'alerter
sur l'état moribond de l'hôpital seront
ils entendus
je crois qu'il ya un problème qui
asphyxie le qitâl à l'heure actuelle qui
est un problème budgétaire
les hôpitaux sont en déficit budgétaire
extrêmement important et ce serait des
entreprises privées il serait fermée
depuis longtemps voilà
faites vous confiance à l'hôpital
c'est la question que l'ifop à poser aux
français sur ce sujet nous allons
connaître l'opinion publique et nous
demander si elle a raison avec nous ce
soir pour en parler bernard kouchner
bonsoir bernard kouchner docteur en
médecine fondateur de médecins sans
frontières puis de médecins du monde
ex ministre de la santé ancien
représentant spécial de l'onu au kosovo
vous rêvez d'une sécurité sociale
mondiale lui dans le débat ce soir et
entendu on va parler de la loi kouchner
la loi sur l'indemnisation des malades
une question avant de présenter vos
assesseurs faites vous confiance à
l'hôpital bernard kouchner
oui patrick peloux bonsoir médecin
urgentiste depuis plus de 20 ans
vous avez vu la situation se dégrader au
fil des ans et tous les ans d'ailleurs
vous alerter les autorités sur
l'engorgement des services des urgences
est d'ailleurs l'été dernier vous avez
été le premier patrick peloux a donné l'
alerte devant la gravité des effets de
la canicule
le 10 août dans le parisien vous
déclariez c'est une véritable hécatombe
les vieux meurent de chaud
certains voient en vous le nouveau
kouchner c'est vrai que j'avais décidé
au regard de devenir médecin
non mais c'est vrai vous savez bernard
qu'il a décidé de devenir médecin en
vous voyant sauver des boat people dans
la mer de chine donc voilà il est plus
vieux que moi
c'était tout si vous le trouvez comment
bernard je trouve pas mal pas mal hein
belle gueule grande gueule volcker alors
patrick peloux faites vous confiance à
l'hôpital oui alain michel ceretti
bonsoir vous êtes président du bien qui
la principale association de lutte
contre les infections nosocomiales 800
mille cas par an 4000 décès et vous vous
en êtes à 500 procédures contre des
établissements privés ou publics
alors vous avez été amené à vous occuper
des victimes des infections nosocomiales
car votre femme béatrice a été opéré en
1991 à la clinique du sport pour un
banal problème de hernie
aujourd'hui elle est paralysée dans son
lit une semaine sur deux elle ne peut
plus exercer son métier d'hôtesse de
l'air et elle n'a pas vu grandir vos
deux enfants
en fait votre épouse a été contaminée
par une bactérie qui s'appelle xenopie à
la clinique du sport et elle n'a pas été
averti par la clinique pendant des
années pendant six ans cette bactérie
xenopie lua lua ronger la colonne
vertébrale et et finalement le jugement
aujourd'hui n'est toujours pas rendu les
victimes n'ont toujours pas été
indemnisés alors si je vous dis faites
vous confiance et l'hôpital je peux pas
dire non mais je n'irai pas à tous
un pas à tous jean carlet bonsoir
bonsoir
helsinn réanimateur à l'hôpital
saint-joseph de paris président du
comité technique national de lutte
contre les infections nosocomiales
une question simple faites vous
confiance à l'hôpital je fais confiance
à l'hôpital pas peut-être pas à tous on
en parlera
ouais on que globalement ma réponse est
oui certainement vite bien en rêve et
non pas angèle piquemal bonsoir j'ai
directeur du centre hospitalier de
bayonne évidemment d'où ce si vous êtes
président de la conférence des
directeurs de centres hospitaliers porte
parole les directeurs de centre
hospitalier auprès du ministère de la
santé
est ce que vous faites confiance à
l'hôpital oui complètement nous faisons
confiance dans les acteurs de l'hôpital
peut-être nous pourrions peut-être moins
confiance dans ce qu'ils voient
uniquement dans l'hôpital ni lourd et
qui ne voient pas suffisamment qui ne
pensent pas suffisamment politique de
santé merci bien pierre flora vous êtes
président du gtm le groupement
temporaire des assureurs médicaux faites
vous confiance à l'hôpital bien merci
messieurs nous allons maintenant avoir
la vie des français et les résultats du
sondage national ifop faites vous
confiance à l'hôpital
[Musique]
91% des français font confiance à
l'hôpital ce qui veut dire c'est
incroyable parce que malgré ce qu'on a
entendu récemment sur la canicule la
grippe la bronchiolite
les français continuent en grande
majorité à faire confiance à l'hôpital
bernard kouchner est ce que ce résultat
de sondage me surprend mais ça ne me
surprend pas parce qu a pas d'autre
choix
quand on est malade on va à l'hôpital on
veut pas être malade et on veut que
l'hôpital soit bon je pense aussi que
les hôpitaux français que le personnel
que la technique est excellent par
rapport au reste du monde mais je mets
en garde parce que on a peur de dire du
mal de l'hôpital on a peur de dire du
mal de son médecin parce que c'est de
soi même qu'il est question mais je suis
bien d'accord ils manquent de
l'information de la transparence
l'hôpital ça doit pas être hôpital
silence mais hôpital transparence
patrick peloux 91% des français c'est
beaucoup quand même surtout pour passer
votre temps à gueuler comme très content
relations publiques
non mais va vous pourriez parce que
finalement c'est au contraire d'alerter
l'opinion publique allemande où il ya 81
11 % des gens qui pensent que tout va
bien mais on était là cet été ouais
c'est les pouvoirs publics qui était pas
trop là nous on était là le personnel
s'est mobilisé on a pu comme on a pu
sauver des vies 91% basse et 91% de
raison de faire mieux probablement mais
ça se fait pas sans moyens
c'est bien sûr vous avez raison une
raison d'informations aussi et que
finalement le corps médical soit pas en
lutte ou en combat avec les malades
un jeune ceretti 91% oui mais je crois
que je fais partie de ceux là nous avons
j'ai confiance nous avons confiance en
l'institution et nous savons que
derrière l'institution il ya des hommes
et des femmes qui se dévouent tous les
jours parce que c'est plus un métier
c'est un sacerdoce de travailler à
l'hôpital
donc nous avons confiance en ces gens là
maintenant est-ce que l'hôpital rend le
service qui devrait rendre jusqu'au bout
on va en parler d'accord en réel tic mal
91% ça vous surprend faire confiance ça
ne veut pas dire non plus à tester que
tout soit positif c'est pas ça c'était
pas la question
les 91 % de français doivent pouvoir
penser qu'il ya effectivement un certain
nombre de problèmes c'est clair nous les
avons identifiés nous allons continuer à
les identifier ils les identifie mais je
pense également qui nous font confiance
pour traiter ces problèmes là parce que
la confiance s'est pas uniquement la
prestation qui est apportée je pense
mais également c'est la confiance à la
capacité de quelques heures à traiter
des difficultés
merci je crois la merci de son carnet
vous êtes surpris par ces chiffres
oui je suis un peu surpris j'avais peur
que les français moins confiance dans
l'hôpital enfin je suis ravi parce que
je pense que les français ne se sont pas
laissés prendre
marc les apprentis sorciers qui essaie
quand même je trouve que c'est très
dangereux de jouer avec l'hôpital de
cette façon et je suis très content
qu'ils se soient pas laissés prendre
cas florent je ne suis pas étonné par
les 90% de je crois que l'hôpital fait
partie de la dette du pays dont il est à
la fois des paysages et ils ont
confiance dans ce qui se passait ils ont
confiance aussi dans les responsables
pour remédier au problème
tôt ou tard qui peuvent si bien roulé
sans merci la fureur font partie des 91
% bien vous guillaume depardieu est ce
que ce résultat de sondage vous surprend
non non ne surprend pas hier que voulait
d'avoir vos problèmes faisait confiance
à l'hôpital exactement
vous pensez que c'est des français font
confiance à l'hôpital c'est parce qu'ils
ont de se former se sont pas informés
d'accord simplement bien donc vous avez
des questions chères amies du du panel
des questions d'abord pour notre ami
guillaume depardieu
on commence avec vous jacques oui cet
accident malheureux dont vous avez été
victime at il été pour vous une
révélation une révélation
oui sur sur plein de choses en fait j'ai
appris plein de choses sur sur l'état
désastreux
contrairement à ce que je
donc on sait que pensent les français
moi j'ai vécu
franchement de l'intérieur c'est
peut-être pas du tout paraît donc de
l'intérieur le cas l'état désastreux
dans lequel le fonctionnent l'hôpital
j'ai pas dit que l'hôpital était mauvais
j'ai dit dans l'état d'esprit dans
lequel il fonctionnait et ça je me
ferais pas contredire par par les gens
qui m'ont soigné
oui c'était une révélation dans le sens
que vous fermez a révélé effectivement
que bon j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à
savoir déjà ce que j'avais appris
beaucoup de choses
c'était une révélation de savoir qu'on
pouvait encore mentir en 2003 surtout
sur des problèmes de santé
et ça m'a appris encore beaucoup de
choses sur le fait que c'est pas très
agréable de se retrouver comme ça à
priver d'un ordre du jour au lendemain
quasiment et puis de toute façon c'est
moi qui l'ait souhaitait parce que
c'était imputable à une école de à une
école de pensée de kehl dans laquelle la
médecine était où il fallait penser pea
nsr avec des douleurs avec des
médicaments et enfin bref j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses effectivement mais ça
quel est le prix que j'ai payé c'est un
parcours en quoi c'est un prix énorme
que vous avez payé bio mais en même
temps on c'est vrai que les maladies
nosocomiales sont entrés dans l'esprit
des gens avec vous ben voilà donc
j'aimerais contribuer modestement à ma
part ma modeste
merci clémence moi j'ai une question un
petit peu dur pour vous je sais que
certains de vos médecins
espérer une alternative à votre
amputations et vous vous avez quand même
préféré prendre les devants
donc je n'hésitais pas un acte de plus
d'auto destruction de votre part
absolument pas non non non c'est au
contraire un acte de construction parce
que j'en avais marre justement de
souffrir le martyr alors qu'on ne
voulait pas me dire ce que j'avais alors
que j'avais mal du soir au matin et du
matin au soir je sais pas si vous pouvez
imaginer ce que c'est que à chaque fois
que vous respirez vous avez mal ça me
paraît donc je pense qu'il ya que ceux
qui ont mal qu'ils peuvent comprendre
enfin bref de toute façon à partir de là
moi j'ai décidé maintenant un an avant
de le faire j'ai décidé maintenant c'est
terminé je coupe la seule alternative
que j'avais c'était un arc rodez qui a
plus ou moins long terme c'est à dire de
5 à 10 ans ont donné une arthrodèse
c'est une jambe tout raid qui vous
donnera des complications je suis désolé
de le dire mais dans dix ans vous on
sera obligé de vous opérer de la hanche
pour vous changer nos hanches rentre
vite ont pesé opéra de plus à ce moment
là je savais que je risque d'attraper
une autre infection nosocomiale et
personne ne le savait personne aucun
français pourrait le savoir très bien
yoann on a bien compris que vous avez
vous avez fait les frais d'un
dysfonctionnement très très regrettable
si on a bien compris mais vous avez
déclaré que c'est une injustice
alors en quoi c'est une injustice quelle
est la justice à laquelle vous auriez
aimé être soumis alors la justice c'est
à dire la justice était déjà de traiter
les hommes de manière humaine finalement
finalement c'est dire qu'on nous dise ce
que j'ai et comment je l'appréhendais
parce que personne n'est pas pareil on
ne réagit pas de la même manière à une
situation qu'on annonce donc non c'est
aussi ce derrière ça que se cache le
corps médical pour ne rien dire
finalement donc c'est ça c'est tout à
fait regrettable
donc la justice dans ce dans les
hôpitaux il y en a pas vraiment ce
serait l'information c'est ça que
voulait dire la justice peut-être ce
sens à son nom et surtout la gestion de
cette information par le personnel
hospitalier et les responsables
politiques qui tiennent en main lesquels
les clés de la bourse
d'ailleurs je crois je veux pas michel
ceretti votre femme a été avertie
combien de d'années après son opa
a sion qu'il y avait ce problème de riz
conférer au père est contaminé en 91 la
clinique c'est à partir de 93 pas que
pour elle peut-être on a vu dans le film
il 4700 personnes rappelées et bien en
ce qui la concerne à la jamais été
informé et c'est pratiquement mourante
en 97 que l'hôpital cochin lui a dit
vous savez vous avez été opéré à la
clinique du sport en 91
on l'avait oublié ben ça doit être ça ça
doit être ça voilà y'a pas grand chose a
ajouté jacques une question pour
guillaume un oui qui ont une dernière
question avez vous déposé plainte suite
à cet incident contre qui avec
constitution de partie civile
et dans quel but mais moi j'ai pas eu le
temps de le faire en fait parce que bon
j'ai même pas le temps je sais même pas
que ce que je peux faire est ce que je
dois faire ça bien oui guillaume vous
seriez vous intéressé au sort des
personnes ayant contracté une maladie
nosocomiale
si vous même vous n'aviez pas été touché
ben non parce que déjà je pense que
spontanément les médecins ne m'aurait
pas fait part de ce cadre du ce genre de
problèmes dans les hôpitaux rencontré
parce qu'il ya eu aussi moi je pense
personnellement qu'il ya une petite
culture du secret quand même dans le
milieu médical que moi je réprouve à
200%
enfin bref j'ai reçu par exemple des
lettres comme celle ci je vous la lyre
j'espère que ça évitera d'autres
questions laissées débute le 6 juin 2003
lorsque mon ami c'est ya pas si
longtemps un mois j'ai reçu à peu près
dix mille lettres comme ça du fait que
un jour mais c'est vous qui m'avez posé
la question justement je suis arrivé en
fait en train de faire la promotion du
film m'a dit mais pourquoi vous avez
encore des béquilles ben je vous ai
répondu eh ben voilà je ne savais pas ce
que j'avais à se pendre
eh ben je les suis trois ans après lui
donc c'est en juin 2003 il apprend que
son amie enceinte de six mois
l'appel de ce long travail quel père et
car elle perd énormément de sang jeudi
en passant que son amie est enceinte et
qu'elle va accoucher je vais donc la
chercher et un quart d'heure après son
ami son appel téléphonique
elle arrive au service maternité de
l'hôpital de chalon la maternité prend
en charge son ami et décide de la
transférer par hélicoptère se parlent
sans vente sur le centre hospitalier
maison blanche située à reims au 45 rue
cognacq-jay arrivée au service des
urgences de la maternité cet hôpital
mon ami refait une hémorragie et le
personnel hospitalier devant l'urgence
de la situation
d
de l'opérer sur le champ sans attendre
d'arriver dans une salle de travail
en arrivant par ses propres moyens dans
cet hôpital donc l'homme à 14h30 apprend
que son ami est en salle de réveil et
que le bébé se portent bien il s'agit
d'une petite fille arrivée à six mois de
grossesse
pesant 1 kg et meuse en mesurant 36 cm
la petite coralie nom qui lui avait
destiné respire seulement et le
personnel médical est optimiste il peut
voir sa fille le même jour en fin
d'après midi elle est si belle mon ami
est ensuite remonté au service des
grosses des grossesses à risque où elle
se repose de sa césarienne évidemment
c'est fatigant notre fille est quant à
elle sous couveuse au service du rip de
l'hôpital son ami sort de la maternité
le 11 juin 2003 à 14h environ donc cinq
jours après durant six jours nous avons
pu voir notre fille quotidiennement
respectant les règles d'hygiène en
vigueur dans ce service
ce 11 juin 2003 avant de quitter
l'hôpital
il rend visite aux services sur ebay
afin de voir son bébé et de la filmer
bien lui en prit car ce sera la dernière
fois qu'il avait ras les infirmières
présentes nous explique qu'une fois
notre départ coralie sera perfusé au
bras et non plus dans le nombril et que
la dernière prise de sang leur indiquer
la présence d'un petit virus aussi
coralie sera t elle mise sous
antibiotiques
nous quittons les lieux le 11 juin 2003
à 17h et rentrons sur châlons en
champagne
en sachant que nous rendrons visite à
notre bout de chou rester à reims
régulièrement jusqu'à sa sortie de
couveuses le 12 juin 2003 à 4h50 du
matin soit exactement douze heures après
son départ
le pauvre homme de race et après avoir
vu sa fille une dernière fois un coup de
téléphone ou réveil un médecin nous
apprend que coralie est décédé à 4h30
des suites d'une infection qui a couvert
depuis trois jours donc une infection
nosocomiale
depuis nous vivons dans la peine d'avoir
perdu notre enfant et nous posons
beaucoup de questions
donc j'espère vous donner je vous donne
justement un lys questions que moi je
m'adresse à moi citoyen la première
question c'est pourquoi ce médecin nous
dit que coralie décédé des suites d'un
staphylocoque qu'elle avait en elle
depuis trois jours alors que les
infirmières nous disait 12 heures
auparavant qu'elle venait juste de
s'apercevoir que notre bébé avait
attrapé un virus mais qu'il ne fallait
pas s'inquiéter donc on revient
finalement au terme de la situation un
peu mensongère que moi qui me scandalise
de plusieurs personnes amis ou famille
et nous ont parlé d' infections
nosocomiales infections que notre petit
aurait pu attraper pu l'attraper
suite à l'intervention rapide à la
maternité de
déjà on entend encore non dans ce qu'on
devrait dénoncer encore une fois une
fois de plus ces mêmes personnes nous
ont conseillé de porter plainte contre
l'hôpital ce que nous refusons à faire
pour le moment sachant que cela ne nous
ramènera pas notre coralie et qu'il
s'agisse s'agirait d'un procès perdu
d'avancé alors là je vous dis non porté
plainte
en tout cas adressez vous aux liens
l'association de monsieur restait
réticent tout cas si vous avez un
dossier médical complet fait le
quatrième manche j'ai demandé par
courrier le 20 juin 2003 à l'hôpital de
reims le dossier médical de ma fille
cinquièmement mon ami et moi sommes
perdus et ne savons que faire nous avons
eu connaissance de votre association et
nous vous demandons conseils pour savoir
la vérité sur la raison ayant entraîné
la disparition brutale de notre bébé que
nous aurons vu finalement seulement six
jours
qu'est ce que voulez je vous dise de
plus là dessus bon moi je suis désolé je
trouve ça scandaleux
alors vous faites des rapports c'est
très bien moi je subis et sept personnes
suivies aussi la perte de son enfant d'à
peine trois jours donc les infections
nosocomiales en france voilà pour les
questions vous avez quelques forme de
réponse de l'état ou en eau mais moi ce
que je voudrais dire c'est envoyer des
dons au système associatif donc parce
que c'est vraiment ce qui est le seul
moyen tournait d'en savoir un peu plus
et ce système associatif c'est à dire
aux liens au lien voici absolument pas
ce que ou plutôt que d'envoyer du
courrier et en plus active parce que moi
je ne peux pas représenter tout seul
j'ai pas les non seulement ni les
finances ni le dispositif ni le
secrétariat
c'est énorme ce que je reçois comme
courrier mais c'est pas moi qu'il faut
l'envoyer
c'est au lien
[Musique]
le bien public donc fait confiance à 91%
à l'hôpital at elle tort ou at elle
raison cette opinion publique nous
allons maintenant ici de la remettre en
cause car il ya quand même des raisons
de s'inquiéter des raisons liées à
l'hygiène des raisons liées au personnel
des raisons liées aux réglementations
alors on va commencer avec l'hygiène ces
bactéries microbes virus responsable des
infections nosocomiales c'est comme le
staphylocoque doré dans guillaume
depardieu a été victime la bactérie
xenopie dont votre épouse
alain michel ceretti a été victime la
légionellose du centre pompidou alors
tous ces virus et microbes et bactéries
prolifèrent par manque d'hygiène dans
les conduits d'eau dans les conduits
d'air et sur les mains du personnel
soignant il fallait qu'ils savent les
mâts 80 fois par jour avec un solutré
hydro hydro alcoolique et ils ne font
pas voilà ça c'est tout bête finalement
c'est le 1d problème numéro 1 est un
problème simple c'est qu'à l'école quand
on était petit ou à la maison nous
apprenait à nous laver les mains alors
on peut s'étonner qu'aujourd'hui le
personnel soignant le ne fasse pas pas
des fois il ya plus d'argent pour en
avoir
ouais du soluté hydroalcoolique richer
le sari bien sûr oui mais c'est à dire
que non mais c'est important c'est à
dire qu'ils sont les gens se lave pas
les mains avec ce produit spécial parce
que maintenant non pas des fois ça n'est
arrivé vous inquiétez vous tiens
pourquoi il y en a pas il ya rupture de
stock où il ya plus de sous mais dont 70
% des infections nosocomiales est vital
parce que leur part les infections mais
y en a malheureusement contre lesquelles
on peut rien 20 ateliers des gens qui
sont en réalité des coûts qui vont
mourir à lang la l'affection précipite
un peu la mort mais y en a beaucoup dont
celle de guillaume d'autres qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure qui sont parfaitement
évitable 70 % des infections évitables
sont les américains qui le disent sont
portés par les mains les mains voilà les
mains 70% les mains par seulement par le
personnel par les visiteurs également
mais en soi sans les % c'est
physiquement qu'on les transporte alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour ça
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ce que vous
avez dit je pense qu'il faut cliquer
viennent les mesures élémentaires pour
le personnel ne dit pas qu'on peut pas
se laver les
les mains 80 faut d'abord s'est pas
forcé d'avoir 80 fois le faire mais le
plus possible et ça n'est pas nous avons
tous fréquenté de très longues années
les hôpitaux ont cette hygiène là en
france n'est pas suffisamment assurée
mais c'est pas seulement ça il y a
beaucoup de mesures qui ont coûté très
cher qui étaient imposées aux hôpitaux
imposé en termes d'hygiène n'est ce pas
il ya des endroits qui sont dans les
hôpitaux connu pour être beaucoup plus
dangereux que d'autres en termes de
propagation bactériennes et virales
alors oui nous essayons de réduire tout
cela et ça se fera sur de l'ombre et
jean-karl et vous avec les clins vous
êtes chargé de faire de la prévention de
faire la surveillance
le problème c'est que vous n'avez pas de
pouvoir en fait de deux sanctions vous
pouvez regarder vous pouvez mesurer mais
si vous voyez par exemple à l'hôpital où
personne se lave les mains vous le
signaler mais ça changera rien on n'y a
pas de pouvoir de sanction se sont
scindés d'asthme et drass qui peuvent
sanctionner mais il ya un pouvoir de
conviction tout la qualité consiste à
tirer les choses vers le haut pas
sanctionné ca et cc on en est assez
convaincu mais juste pour reprendre ce
que vous disiez sur les staphylocoques
les férus cela en faisant un une salade
niçoise s'est pas non attendez vous
dites une salade niçoise et je suis
désolé mais il sa femme ça fait jaser
mois à la passe et affamés dans la
colonne vertébrale bouffer par la
xenopie et vous dis c'est une salade
niçoise il a plus de gens m'ont dit que
si une seule je vous ai de la chance de
tomber sur les routes hier c'est que les
staphylocoques c'est pas des bactéries
qu'on trouve à l'hôpital 30% de la
population saine en a dans les 70 % des
infections postopératoires sont liées
aux mêmes staphylocoques que celui qu'on
avait dans le nez le même au sens où
c'est la même passion le nom des gens et
bien sûr vous avez simplement parce
qu'on en est à ce point là au plan
scientifique dans le monde non monsieur
car les voilà avec dans monsieur carle
et ses fausses et je suis désolé c'est
maintenant ça suffit maintenant s'il
vous plaît je pars faire du
catastrophisme que parce que c'est ce
que vous dites on ne pouvait pas faire
de catastrophisme mais le sur quoi que
ce fût le nombre de morts on pourrait
quand même qui est quand même qui frôle
les 10 mille c'est pas du catastrophisme
parents je précise par an et les
infections dont je ne vous aime pas
vous dire le nombre d'infections en tout
cas moi le courrier que je reçois sait
absolument pas ce que vous dites qui va
me faire changer d'avis sur ce que je
pense de l'hygiène dans les hôpitaux
donc il n'y a pas d'argent de toute
façon ça c'est clair il n'y a pas de
personnel
il n'ya d'eau passe donc parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'argent ce qu'il voit de cause à
effet d'accord que ce soit bien clair
moi je veux pas entendre des choses
comme ça vous êtes chargés de remettre
un rapport au gouvernement
un responsable mais d'abord vous n'êtes
pas responsables non mais la zone choi
voi normal et c'est un match à ma
position aujourd'hui quand j'entends ça
moi je veux montois qui était d'ailleurs
temps on vous dit le nez vous dites on a
des accents de coke à l'emmener si vous
le savez pourquoi quand quelqu'un arrive
dans un hôpital on commence par ça
commence pas par le décontaminer tout
simplement déjà rien que dans l'état
actuel de la recherche les autres pays
ne le font pas c'est quelque chose qui
est en train d'être discuté en france
comme ailleurs on est simplement à la
limite de ce que l'on connaisse
scientifiquement et simplement
probablement de l'échelle c'est un peu
pour noyer le poisson c'est la verrait
bien qu'on s'attaque à des souches
résistantes ski de anthem de
bactériologie effectivement mais ça ce
sont une politique de santé qui date
d'il ya 30 ans dont on a développé des
antibiotiques surpuissant maintenant
effectivement créer des souches précisé
pas le cas en suède
les gens s'en sent moins résistants en
tout cas comme on le sait depuis ce que
vous dites si bien puisque vous le savez
vous êtes chargé de le dire et de faire
de faire appliquer en tout cas par le
ministère de la santé que tout le monde
paye ici d'ailleurs bon soit dit en
passant
donc à ce moment là où va tout cet
argent
non mais non s'il vous plaît je veux par
le pénis et le débat là mais jeudi il ya
quand même des chiffres qui sont
astronomiques
on ne fait certainement pas le soluté
6,3 est facile de dire qui a pas assez
d'argent quand on veut pas en donner
plus parce que s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît
oui il n'ya pas assez d'argent il y en a
jamais assez et personne ne dit mais
enfin il faut combien sont maintenant le
faire entendre
ça coûtera toujours plus cher nous
vivons plus vieux
nous avons une technique plus cher ça
coûtera toujours plus cher donc
évidemment vous avez raison il n'y a pas
assez d'argent c'est pas seulement pour
des raisons financières qu'on n'a pas
d'hygiène dans les zones seront pas
suffisants par exemple dans son rapport
monsieur car les demandes
il soulève des points que moi je n'ai
pas qu'ils sont incontestables qui
relève du domaine du fait tout
simplement
c'est effectivement on pourrait même
décider tout simplement des pistes et
puisque c'est le principal porteur la
principale cause de problèmes
d'infections nosocomiales c'est le
porter lui-même quand il rentre les gens
rien simplement lui faire prendre une
douche avec des produits qu'il faut rien
que ça déjà et où même lui nettoyer le
nez donc rien que cela c'est sa part est
débile à des problèmes d'hygiène voilà
simplement voilà ta triclasse sur
l'argent pour s'acheter de quoi se laver
les mains parce que ça me semble
tellement tellement simple comme fait
géré ça c'est pas de la théorie c'est si
vous n'avez pas de blé pour vous les
avez sous les yeux du savon de marseille
non mais non mais c'est ce qui vient de
dire bernard il a dit ça parce que c'est
arrivé une fois ou deux mais enfin quand
même c'est faux c'est fou c'est pas faux
et ça va c'est pas fou l'audit des dieux
cette fois ci c'est pas faux c'est par
les grands prix tombait gélinas vous
parlait très bien vous avez une fois
très chaud mais c'est le jeu social
c'est peu lukic et la voix de la france
voilà c'est ça on sait les autorités
voient la vie en france s'est longtemps
de l'autorité voilà du tout tout va bien
mais c'est en tout cas le vin et changer
de genre des rapports je n'ai jamais dit
ça va tout va mieux alors si alors
qu'elle savait de quoi vous laver les
mains dans la réalité il ya souvent des
hôpitaux qui sont dans telle restriction
budgétaire qu'il faut faire des choix
il est pas rare qu'ils aient pendant une
courte période de rupture de stock qui
arrivent d'un coup hop il ya plus il ya
plus de produits de la priorité c'est
fort et vous êtes toujours là quoi
ce jour là c'est quand même impensable
mais bon bien vous avez des questions à
poser à tout le monde ici sur ce
problème donc de tuyaux d'air de tuyaux
d'eau et de lavage de mains tout
simplement qu'il veut parler
samia je vous écoute moi ça me choque un
petit peu parce qu'on est quand même en
france on est dans un pays où on a un
système médical extrêmement développé on
a la chance d'avoir d'excellents
médecins et cetera alors qu'on me dise
que parce qu'il ya plus de savon j'ai
perdu une jambe ou comme la femme de ce
monsieur je me fais ranger la colonne
vertébrale je trouve ça très grave
alors est-ce qu'on va se décider à faire
prendre de nouvelles habitudes aux
personnels hospitaliers à se laver les
mains chaque fois le problème du lavage
des mains en france n'est pas lié à un
manque de moyens
je veux absolument pas exact deux
habitués aux habitudes 2 alors on l'a on
à l'hygiène qu'on mérite socialement les
français moyen ne se lave pas les mains
ce de façon tout à fait flagrante par
rapport à d'autres pays comme les
hollandais
troisième chose que la consommation de
sa troisième chose les infections
postopératoires sont vraiment le
problème qui focalisent notre angoisse à
tous est celle de nos deux invités
victimes ne sont prince pas
principalement liée à un problème de
lavage des mains je vous le dis
carrément elles sont liées à d'autres
problèmes et d'autres problèmes qui
nécessitent qu urgemment la conférence
qui nous sommes et xénon bi
sinon c'était n'existe en particulier ce
n'est pas le lavage des mains c'était
lavage des instruments voilà donc c'est
pas la vache de vie s'arrête à fait
spéciale par rapport à la quantité
d'infections nosocomiales c'est une
super opportunité du score à
staphylocoque après intervention
chirurgicale qui sont la plaie en ce
moment pas que dans notre pays dans tous
les pays ne sont pas principalement lien
problème de lavage des mains scellier
soit allant transmission peropératoire
du staphylocoque porté par le nez et
éventuellement du livre à l'adresse des
soignants qui sont dans le bloc soit
beaucoup plus souvent le passage des
staphylocoques qui sont sur l'année où
la pohdh des malades qui le portent en
entrant à l'hôpital et rien à 30%
d'entre nous en ont dans le nez et qui
parviennent dans le champ opératoire
soit en très petites quantités qu'ils
ont
une affection parce que le malade s'est
pas défendu soit en trop grosse quantité
et là il ya une erreur mais c'est très
compliqué et on est actuellement si vous
ne croyez pas tant pis mais c'est la
vérité aux limites de ce que l'on
connaît au monde le vin à penser comme
les autres pays
non mais bon à ce moment là moi je vous
entends monsieur carle m est
complètement dérisoire finalement nos
problèmes mon moi mon problème il est
complètement
vous me voyez là dessus et avait
travaillé la salle problème sur le fait
qu'un vol avait un malade avant qui vole
en rien cela face à levante un seul
avant de libérer cette modération et un
mental
il faudrait donc que moi j'avais
l'impression qu'on me l'avait enfin
avant d'entrer en salle d'opération
oui mais y aller vous avez passé toute
l'année pour dire ça c'est vous avez
travaillé toute une année pour donner
sera nord donc les antiseptiques faux
pas c'est généralement la flore en
baisse de n'héberger on doit savoir et
moi c'est ça que vous demandez si c'est
vrai c'est pas pourquoi c'est pas fait
parce que c'est là pourquoi c'est pas
fait ça c'est un document interne au
ministère de la santé qui est
extrêmement récente date du mois dernier
c'est un groupe de travail qui travaille
sur les infections nosocomiales et à la
diffusion d'information au grand public
ses désirs nous bien est une des
informations qu'on voudrait pouvoir
diffuser ces retours d'infections
nosocomiales en post opératoire après
une chirurgie et bien le représentant de
l'ap-hp et en particulier de la
salpêtrière voilà ce qui dit je cite la
question d'une surveillance à la carte
plus fine et adaptés à certains services
ou activité est intéressante précise le
docteur robert précise que le problème
actuel auquel on doit répondre et que
80% des services de chirurgie c'est bien
entendu 80% des services de chirurgie ne
font pas de surveillance des infections
postopératoires proposons leur une
surveillance a minima alors vous êtes en
train de me dire qu'on sait pourquoi les
infections en post opératoire existe
simplement lui qui est dans le bloc i
dia 80% des blocs opératoires qui ne
font pas de surveillance à main je dire
donnez moi la liste des 20 % qui en font
parce que c'est là que je vais me faire
opérer
bien ronarc'h je suis vraiment triste
huppé fait que avec des professionnels
de la santé aujourd'hui on se pose la
problématique de l'hygiène d'accord ça
c'est vraiment une remarque de base ces
femmes sussan stupéfait vraiment ça me
laisse pantois le et là dessus le il y
un problème d'hygiène
ok on est dans une société où économique
non on demande à toutes les entreprises
de faire des audits de faire des mesures
qualité on veut mesurer de la qualité
dans tous les secteurs de l'économie
parce que c'est un vecteur inévitable de
rationalisation de meilleure gestion
l'hygiène ça peut aussi se dit et même
si je ne vous cache pas que sam
stupéfait aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui est
fait pour mesurer la qualité de
l'hygiène dans les hôpitaux risque est
contrôlée mais comment vous contrôler
comment contrôler que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui viennent voir
combien de fois les infirmières unis jsa
qui veut une équipe d'hygiène dans
l'hôpital qui contrôle comme elle peut
parce que c'est un hôpital là où je
travaille il ya 850 lits et un nombre
assez important de service et ils sont
de fait un suffisamment nombreux pour
faire ce qu'ils évoquent c'est à dire
des audits dans tous les services
et c'est extrêmement difficile par
contre il ya des progrès qui ont été
faits notamment dans le lavage des mains
mais c'est de toute façon a suffi michel
une question on passe aux problèmes de
personnel l'audit au choix c'est juste
un maillon coincé après le résultat de
l'audit si si l'audit est négatif et
consorts pas la boîte à gifles ou s'il
est positif et quoi sort pas la boîte de
bonbons
ça sert à rien de faire des autres voilà
ce qu'il faut
bien que c'est le problème des clans à
sanctions contre tous
non non attendez non non j'ai choisi la
solution je dis aussi la boîte avantage
il sait quoi
voilà bah ça quand on a fait des progrès
ou à dormir des choses avant la boîte à
gifles
parce que ça en fait - et la boîte à
bonbons on fait encore moins et l'asse
de publier ce qu'on a trouvé là
évidemment il faut le faire et ça n'est
pas fait dans ce pays bien c'est réservé
suma des ailes sont les mauvais qui vont
perdre leur où il a justement en
publiant le saurai alors on va continuer
on a vu le problème de l'hygiène on va
passer aux problèmes des personnels donc
le fameux problème évidemment des 35
heures
bernard kouchner a déclaré on a oublié
que les malades ne font pas 35 heures
c'est vrai pas servi à grand chose mais
j'ai dit ça et peloux pense
effectivement 35 heures c'est très bien
sauf qu'il n'ya pas eu de moyens
supplémentaires et de personnel
supplémentaire donc les 35 heures ont
été pour l'hôpital une espèce de
catastrophes manque d'infirmières manque
de personnel il ya plus d'un terne
il ya beaucoup moins d'un terne dans les
hôpitaux qu'avant il ya moins 50% d'un
terne dans les hôpitaux
parce que plus personne de fer
cancérologue comme boulot coller mais
qui préfère être en ville avec des
cabinets donc ils sont plus interne
les urgences sont engorgés car les
généralistes ne veulent plus faire la
nuit et le week-end voilà ça fait partie
des choses qui rendent l'hôpital plus
dangereux disons c'était c'était c'était
évident que dans toute façon s'il y
avait je reste je reste convaincu sylvie
un endroit où il fallait une
amélioration sociale pour rendre ce
métier attrayant pour justement il ya un
progrès par rapport à sa difficulté
c'était probablement sur l'hôpital les
faire comme ça a été fait c'était un
casse tête parce que bien entendu les
écoles d'infirmières avait été fermée un
certain nombre avaient été fermées en 97
par par le précédent plan juppé ce avait
posé des problèmes
et quand on a décidé enfin quand ils ont
décidé de faire les 35 heures ils sont à
mon sens allait beaucoup trop vite s'est
cumulé pour le corps médical
j'ai envie de dire enfin une
reconnaissance légitime du temps de
travail de nuit c'est à dire quand nous
sommes deux gardes quand on intervient
en camion de ce mur sur les voies
publiques à 2 heures du matin quand on
est garde en réanimation au bloc
opératoire la nuit
tout ça il faut comprendre que c'était
du temps de travail qui n'existaient pas
c'était quelque chose qui n'existait pas
l'europe est arrivé à 10 cd le travail
c'est du travail qui doit être reconnu
comme dans tout métier pour ceux qui
travaillent la nuit ils comprennent bien
ce que je veux dire
et donc ça a dû être appliquée mais là
encore ça a été appliquée dans des
disciplines d'abord qui était pas très
attrayante parce qu'évidemment c'est
vrai c'est ça c'est à dire qu'en fait il
ya des vaut mieux faire un métier on est
sûr pas de faire de garde ne pas avoir
permanence deux personnes de se faire
chier quoi c'est ça le problème
enfin je vais moi mais en tout cas même
moi tout ce que j'ai pu voir tu peux
constater de mon expérience c'est qu'il
ya vraiment pas d'effectif et comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
d'argent pour payer des gens tout
simplement et donc monsieur kouchner
vaucher la tête mais non je suis
d'accord ritalin mais oui mais vous me
dites vous oui mais alors en cours
comment faire entendre aux gens qui
doivent gagner plus comme ça c'est ça ou
alors comme ça donc est alors très bien
je vous dis donc chers français chef
français votre argent va nulle part en
tout cas ils ont très mal utilisé je me
suis en tout cas les donc les gens qui
travaillent à l'hôpital les infirmiers
et les infirmières ce qu'ils sont en
train de travailler et les médecins
urgentistes donc à ce moment là il faut
savoir qu'on ne veut pas faire ce métier
parce que d'abord c'est hector
extrêmement mal payé ça je peux vous le
dire par rapport au travail qu'on doit
fournir et en plus on ne peut pas
puisque alors qu'on accepte et voter ses
35 heures vous n'aurez pas le droit aux
35 heures de toute façon il n'y avait
même pas le droit maintenant parce que
déjà les moins ce que je connais ne font
accroire à 35 heures si c'est dire aussi
cet été personne n'a compté son temps de
travail
anthony une question pour patrick peloux
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour monsieur
peut louer je voudrais savoir qu'est ce
qu'il fallait faire ah ouais franchement
il faut que lui son ministre
que fallait-il faire concrètement et
tout de suite pour venir à bout du drame
de la canicule qui a eu lieu cet été
bon vous avez travaillé à 200% merci
beaucoup à tous les français mais qu'est
ce qu'il fallait faire qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait que les politiques décident
concrètement qu'est ce que pouvaient
faire les pouvoirs publics pour éviter
ou prévenir plus exactement ceux là bas
là vous tombez sur un des drames à mon
avis de notre pays c'est que tout est
cloisonné et météo france fait son
boulot dans son coin et le ministère de
l'intérieur fait son boulot dans son
coin demandons ministre je sais qu'il a
voulu à plusieurs reprises essayer
d'avoir du lien en domaine de la santé
avec la sécurité civile qui est détenue
par le ministère de l'intérieur et c'est
très difficile que les que tout le monde
se parle
ce qui fait que vous vous êtes sur le
terrain début août
vous sentez qui va se passer quelque
chose parce qu'on ferme tellement de lit
pardonnez moi monsieur piquemal pour
faire rentrer les budgets dans les clous
parce qu'il faut pas créer d'emplois
parce qu'il ne faut pas ouvrir de lit
donc on peut pas recruter des
infirmières parce que soi-disant il y en
a pas mais celles qui sont en place
veulent quitter la carrière parce que
les échelles de leurs salaires ne sont
pas suffisantes au bout de plusieurs
années ce qui fait qu'elle s'en vont ce
qui fait qu on ferme des lits mais
finalement tout le monde s'en contente
parce que les budgets vont rentrer dans
les clous
ce qui fait que quand fin juillet début
août qu'est ce qui se passe ce que vous
connaissez
certains de nos politiques pas tous mais
certaines politiques sont quand même
complètement à côté de la plaque
c'est ce qui fait la différence entre
eux mêmes politiques et puis un homme
d'état mais l'homme politique qui pense
à la prochaine élection l'inde et à y
penser à la prochaine génération
et si on avait eu à ce moment là des
hommes politiques qui avaient pensé à la
prochaine génération
on n'aurait pas fait ce qu'on a fait
parce qu'on à réguler les coûts en
matière de santé par l'offre on a dit on
va faire moins de médecins comme ça il y
aura moins de mal à passer quand même
qu'on perd le combat d'ardebil
des questions jacques janos une question
une question de technique notamment sur
le manque de personnel comment ça se
fait que déjà dans les années 80 la
gauche qui était en place n'a pas
commencé à régler le problème parce
qu'on va pas le régler en maintenant
parce qu'il ya du recrutement de la
formation et je sais de quoi je parle
puisque je suis fonctionnaire et qu'on a
dans ma fonction publique on a
exactement le même problème comment ça
se fait que déjà dans les années 80 on
n'a pas pris le taureau par les cornes
on a préparé un plan pluriannuel de
recrutements sur plusieurs années et on
aurait peut-être régler une grande
partie du problème aujourd'hui monsieur
kouchner vous avez été ministre à
saintes et j'aimerais bien que vous me
répondez à cette question
moi j'ai augmenté j'ai essayé de
l'augmenter suffisamment mais j'ai
augmenté très largement le nombre des
infirmières et le numerus clausus des
médecins et lorsque nous avons perdu les
élections
c'est pardonnez moi de dire le
gouvernement suivant qui a diminué le
nombre des formations hospitalières et
qui a fermé des écoles et nous les avons
à nouveau et ouvert pas assez alors
parce que les habitudes explique
monsieur kouchner eric et s'ils vont
laisser finir c'est simple une réponse
récusé par le faisait alors les
infirmières dans la rue si vous avez
réglé le problème
répondez-moi les infirmières
traditionnellement ainsi que le
personnel médical
ils protestent et c'est comme ça que les
progrès se font par c'est normal c'est
plié oui c'est un risque a pas de
problème demandait qu'on et laissez moi
parler on ferait pas mal une couleur non
mais vous avez avalé là quand même parce
que vous avez tort non j'avais tort
c'est à dire que nous avons augmenté le
nombre des infirmières seulement il faut
au moins trois ans pour les former et
bien entendu c'est seulement au bout de
trois ans qu'on en voit le résultat
nous avons augmenté très largement n'y a
pas une école qui ne soit maintenant
réouverte mêmes nous en avons créé
d'autres matériels sont pleines
mais il faut trois ans voilà le problème
ce qu'on nous dit maintenant
effectivement c'est effectivement il ya
des infirmières dans les écoles mais
elles sont pas formés dans le parlement
vous n'en avez pas alors gare à venir de
l'étranger
elles vont être formés monsieur piquemal
il ya eu des postes et il ya beaucoup de
postes une liaison pas occupé attention
aux raccourcis le métier d'infirmière et
difficile certains ont profité de la
canicule cet été pour remettre en cause
totalement
seulement la rtt c'est un faux procès
que l'on fait à la rtt parce que si on
imagine qu'une infirmière peut encore
continuer à travailler trois week-ends
sur quatre est d'en avoir qu'un seul de
libre sur quatre on attirera jamais
parce que ce ne serait pas normal et
jeunes filles et les jeunes hommes pour
rentrer dans des instituts de formation
en soins infirmiers or nous avons besoin
d'eux donc il y à aussi à améliorer les
conditions de travail pour faire en
sorte que ça devient très réactif ça ne
l'est pas
ces deux mêmes en ce qui concerne les
médecins je pense qu'il va falloir
arrêter de quelque part faire la
politique de l'autruche augmentation du
numerus clausus oui augmentation du
nombre d'étudiants en médecine oui mais
pour quelle discipline et pour quelle
région
je pose par conséquent deux questions
une question avec deux niveaux la
question de la régulation
nous devons réguler les flux de
spécialistes parce que si nous devons
avoir de mer davantage de médecins dans
des disciplines pour laquelle nous avons
déjà assez et si nous n'avons pas c'est
un anesthésiant pédiatrie en
gynéco-obstétrique en chirurgie en
urgence on aura fait chou blanc
deuxièmement régulation géographique
nous ne voulons pas regarder cette
question là ici en france nous imposer
des installations il faudra que moins de
médecins à s'installer sur certaines
zones
touristiquement attractive pour aller
dans des zones où il y a de la
population n'est par contre qu'ils ont
peut-être effectivement un peu moins
agréable
il faut prendre en compte ce problème de
réguler ce que vous dites là excusez moi
monsieur piquemal mais c'est en fait et
c'est normal l'individualisme propres à
nos sociétés
ben la médecine l'hôpital en est victime
aussi c'est ce que vous êtes en train de
la culture traverse yonnais louisa bien
ce que monsieur piquemal vient de
demander effet depuis trois ans les
études médicales ont changé l'internât
d'abord il n'est pas réservé aux
spécialistes mais maintenant l'internet
pour tous et anime des médecins
généralistes seront formés par
l'internât et 7 en fonction des besoins
de la santé en france que les
disciplines et les spécialités seront
choisis et on ne pourra sauf quand on
sera premier on pourra choisir ce qu'on
veut c'est à la fin qu'on fait de la
chirurgie cardiaque mais tout sera
rendue folle comme ses frères city oui
mais en gros tout ça il va faire
généralistes aaa et à cagnes-sur-mer
attendait des questions dans le panel
oui am
ona rogan jacques oui le problème de la
répartition géographique et peut-être de
la répartition par spécialité peut-être
aussi vous parler de coercition et vous
avez probablement raison mais si c'est
un problème de bateaux ça peut peut-être
aussi un problème de carottes
il ya des prix pour s'installer dans les
pays où on veut pas aller bien
après la boîte à bonbons c'est la
carotte embrasse très bien plus d'une
question on parle de bâton par de
carottes on parle de boîte à gifles
l'emboîtement mais non sur ça je trouve
ça intéressant mais on l'appliqué au
corps médical
ouais je trouve que il faudrait d'abord
penser et dire aux français ce qu'ils
peuvent attendre du service public et en
fonction de ce qu'ils payent un peu dire
l'éducation c'est le corps médical qu'on
voit comme ça derrière la barrière
il faut qu'ils fassent ça il faut qu'il
fait siffleur mètres d'écart est il veut
remettre des bâtons je pense que on ne
pourra pas tirer les cours vers le haut
en permanence parce qu'il faut dire aux
français aussi que le budget de la santé
est voué à augmenter et on pourra pas
trouver de solution sans que les
français at et un comportement plus
citoyen on attend surtout sur la
prévention d'ailleurs surtout sur la
prévention
monsieur carle et un môme il faut qu'on
travaille ensemble
est ce que je voudrais aussi dire c'est
que malgré cette tendance à la baisse du
nombre de personnels la ligier n dans
les hôpitaux est meilleure qu'avant et
la qualité
c'est finalement devant guillaume je
serais vous je dis on va dire aux gens
qu'elle est moins moment pour la
raconter tout ce que vous voulez oui
j'avais dit que je parlerai des
réglementations ya qu'une chose que
qu'on pourrait dire et ça vous ça vous
concerne alain michel ceretti ça serait
d'afficher parce que finalement sur un
bon restaurant il ya quatre étoiles où
il ya quatre toques ça serait d'afficher
sur les sociétés un truc qui vous tient
à coeur d'afficher sur les hôpitaux des
résultats sur par exemple les maladies
nosocomiales souvent 10ème et ceretti
voulait le guide michelin des hôpitaux
mais gillet non je parle guide michelin
2010 et si il faut le guide michelin est
ce que finalement si demain on interdit
le michelin et le gault et millau ça
embête qui est meilleur c'est ce qui
tous les jours font tout pour que garder
lors des soirées toile qui vont être les
premiers évidemment victimes de cette
interdiction
donc je crois que en laissant le système
comme il est dans l'opacité la plus
totale en ne permettant pas aux usagers
qui sont payeur du système de pouvoir
s'orienter correctement est bien la
seule chose qu'on arrive à faire c'est
de donner une prime à la médiocrité mais
tionnel rivaux les meilleurs en on
marginalise boss qui ont leur dis pas
qu'ils sont qui sont bien ça doit être
un combat comme disait notre ami michel
dit c'est une question pour bernard
kouchner
avez vous confiant un conscience que
votre loi excellente au demeurant c'est
n'a pas atteint son but et c'est même un
peu trompé de cible parce que j'ai un
bateau qu'on a frôlé le procès des
médecins ce soir parce que voulait dire
ton petit jeu manhwa été fait pour les
malades elle s'appelle droits des
malades c'est la première fois qu'on
pensait aux malades et non aux médecins
alors dans le système ce qui est
important bien sûr le médecin capitale
mais c'est le malade j'ai pensé que les
droits des malades devaient être
respectés ne serait-ce que l'accès au
dossier médical car si on n'avait pas
fait l'accès au dossier médical et nous
avions vingt ans de retard
on pouvait pas se retourner ou
comprendre même ce qui était arrivé
rien qu'en matière d'infections
nosocomiales et heureusement il n'y a
pas que les infections virales et aussi
toute la série des guérisons et toute la
série des difficultés et de la
compréhension nécessaire pour guérir il
faut être deux pas seulement le médecin
mais le malade qui doit comprendre et
qui aide à sa guérison et qui participe
de toutes ses forces
je ne pense pas m'être trompé de cible
je ne suis pas trompé à propos des
assureurs je pense qu'ils doivent
revenir sur des primes plus raisonnable
est que la loi à bout doit être revue
parce qu'il avait promis de revenir dans
le système et il ne sommes pas revenus
et je pense que ça doit se faire très
vite parce que ce serait pas raisonnable
de le faire il y aura je les garde dans
le corps médical
ismaël le guillaume lekeu pensez-vous de
la loi kouchner
bah je pense que c'est quand même dans
ce sens là qu'il faut aller c'est que
91% des français font confiance à
bernard kouchner bien sûr c'est long ça
qui peut aller et pas du tout dans le
sens de l'obscurantisme
c'est surtout aussi avec l'ensemble des
partenaires du budget autour de moi vous
je pense qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
travail à faire en terme de
communication d'informations et surtout
de gestion est-ce que vous avez un
portefeuille et surtout donc dit de
clamer haut et fort que vous n'avez pas
assez d'argent je suis désolé de vous
décevoir là dessus monsieur mais en tout
cas il n'y a pas assez d'argent c'est
clair pour tout ce dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui
les assurances peuvent éventuellement
bloquer ou retarder les indemnisations
donc de patients ou même le empêcher des
médecins de pratiquer pendant un laps de
temps devenait même très court puisque
des organismes relais ont été mis en
place
lemay aujourd'hui est ce que les
assureurs ont aussi conscience en leur
for intérieur au delà de leur métier que
ce sont malgré tout des êtres humains et
que demain ils peuvent aussi avoir
besoin des praticiens qu'ils peuvent
immobiliser bien sûr le l'organisation
des soins et les hôpitaux les sondages
le montrent a fait partie d'une vie
sociale d'une vie collective
on a sur les voitures n'a sur les
maisons on assure des tas de choses on
assure là
les établissements de soins et les
praticiens depuis depuis un siècle
depuis qu'on a inventé la responsabilité
civile médicale c'est vraiment pas loin
d'un siècle et on le fait depuis très
longtemps oui bien sûr vous assurez mais
on danse les proviseurs si elle
attendait combien il a su bien il faut
pour à gynécologue obstétricien qui y
est on a publié les chiffres 150
accouchement sur 250 qui fait qu'il soit
consacrée à l'assurance
c'est trop je pense que c'est trop je
pense qu'il n'y a pas plus je suis sûr
et certain qu'il ya moins de poursuites
qu'avant peut-être grâce à la loi en
particulier mais grâce aussi à la
compréhension ou à des émissions comme
celle-là je demande aux assureurs qu'ils
reviennent sur une position outrancières
qui fait que les médecins vont s'en
aller de leur métier tant qu'ils ne
pourront plus payer et donc les
assureurs façon vous savez bien commencé
bah oui ça en tête et quand il faut
payer la prime ils sont là depuis quand
il faut rembourser a pu faire ça donc je
pense que ça va s'arranger il faut que
la loi avait alors expliqué nous sommes
heureux d'en arriver là
chaque fois mais alors les primes il est
d'habitude quand on parle de l'assurance
d'enfoncer ce genre en deux j'allais
dire de portes ouvertes
là les assureurs payer une amende chaud
le boulou ben c'est leur boulot mais là
il ya deux choses différentes dont vous
parlez premièrement l'assurance ou la
non-assurance des établissements et des
patriciens et la deuxième chose des
primes
oui voici quand même et primes sont trop
élevés soit là message les voix de prime
automobile est aussi trop élevé si vous
n'avez pas eu d'accident c'est dire si
votre les séries à plus de poursuites il
est faux puisque en a moins on parle de
la profession d imaginer qu un accord
obstétricien qui accouchent là il se
trouve qu'il ya un certain nombre de
gynéco il ya une utilisation qui est
faite entre l'ensemble des gynécos et
les pépins qui peut y avoir en cas
d'accouchement
combien coûte à combien coûte lorsque un
bébé je vous france total plus de pépins
monsieur mais à écouter si on a moins il
vraiment en gagner une fortune vous
assurerez médical ou naturels dure une
forte compétence écoutez moi je vais
parfois j'en vois ma soeur va pas vous
plaindre on va pas vous clouer au pilori
vous êtes de chérac cela en dehors
d'être du gt hamzeh de chez axa on sait
bien que les assureurs ben voilà on sait
bien qu'ils veulent pas assurer ces cas
là on a tous étudié le dossier avant de
venir
on sait bien qu'ils veulent pas alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra qu'il compte
assurer ce qu'il faudrait qu'on me dire
est ce qu'il faut faire si parce que
vous ne vous oblige est assurée oui mais
bien sûr qu'il serait ce que si l'état
de l'état n'a pas le courage de vous
obliger à assurer les gens c'est très
bien de faire
vous savez quand vous avez un des prix
complètement exhorbitant parce que vu
leur donc si finalement il n'y avait pas
de risque à l'hôpital à ce moment là
vous à surveiller avec un large sourire
après son euro par personne et par an
en train de parler des problèmes des
hôpitaux des temps de vie que les autres
cadeaux et l'exercice même de la
médecine c'est pas faux rires oui
d'accord comme s'il n'y avait pas cette
loi qui justement coupe entièrement les
gros coup des assureurs
s'il ya une faute médicale et c'est
quand même des cas assez rare alors là
en effet vous assurez mais maintenant
grâce à cela l'on attendait grâce à
cette loi
l'aléa thérapeutique c'est à dire l'ins
c'est-à-dire l'infection nosocomiale
elle n'est pas assurée par vous mais par
l'hôpital
lequel s'est assurée par les assurés
sociaux qui vont payer j'adore c'est
toujours les mêmes
bonjour benneteau alors on va terminer
avec clémence ma petite clémence la
dernière question adressée à patrick et
moi je voulais savoir si vous alliez
exercer votre mais nous votre profession
quoi qu'il arrive jusqu'au bout ou si
vous pourriez être amené à être dégoûtée
carrément du milieu hospitalier
justement avec le manque de moyens est
abandonnée tout non non ça ferait
longtemps non non non vous savez c'est
bien d'être sûr d'être ici ce soir mais
si j'ai choisi de faire un métier j'en
suis pas encore dégoûté j'ai encore
beaucoup de choses à apprendre des
malades et de et de la fonction est
quelque part en effet c'est vrai que
maintenant c'est un c'est un but je suis
quelque part entré en résistance souvent
en opposition avec des dirigeants
hospitalier parce que je crois que
l'hôpital public a toute sa place dans
notre société qu'il faut lui donner les
moyens
et si de fait de gueuler haut et fort ce
que souvent beaucoup pensent tout bas ça
sert à quelque chose j'espère que ça
sert avant tout chose aux malades
merci beaucoup
conclusion l'opinion publique fait
confiance à l'hôpital at elle raison at
elle tort quand on écoute guillaume
depardieu et patrick peloux on est en
droit de s'inquiéter
en tout cas vous avez désormais les
moyens de vous faire votre opinion à
vous votre opinion privé il pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu